Israeli Minister of Finance meanwhile
Bez smish says Israelis will live in
Gaza he told Israel's Army Radio we must
encourage the residents of Gaza to
immigrate as they live in hardship and
poverty the Israelis want to return to
Gaza because it's a beautiful place and
they will turn the desert into a
prosperous
Place sarra joins us now from Tel Aviv
statements like that will only go to
confirm and alarm people across the
region
right yeah absolutely I mean this
finance minister is also in charge of
the expansion of illegal settlements in
occupied West Bank that was part of the
Coalition deal when the farri uh
government was formed about a year ago
um this is someone who also comes from a
settler background so he's very much in
favor of moving Palestinians out of of
Gaza and bringing in the Israeli
settlers there used to be Israeli
settlements in Gaza up until 2005 but
when the Israeli forces that had
occupied Gaza withdrew they also took
with them the Israeli settlements and
they weren't allowed to stay um this is
a concern especially because um a few
days ago uh the war cabinet was looking
to decide uh to talk about for the first
time uh what's called the day after what
happens once this war ends and it was
because of bezau smotrich uh that they
had to postpone it until Tuesday he
really kicked up quite the fuss saying
that that decisions or those discussions
shouldn't just be uh the war cabinet but
it should include himself and it should
include also uh the rest of the security
cabinet and that's why it's been
postponed till Tuesday on the other hand
you also have Benny gance one of the war
cabinet members that has been voicing
his thoughts in saying that uh what is
the plan next because uh the longer they
leave those discussions uh the longer
it's unclear what happens now someone
like bzar smotri is really uh saying
that um countries like Egypt should take
uh people from Gaza and that he would
encourage voluntary immigration and of
course that would mean the reoccupation
of Gaza now when he says uh that um we
could turn it from Desert into a
prosperous land this is a sentiment
we've been hearing ourselves from some
of the Israelis that one person said to
me once what do they want we left Gaza
in 2005 and it's because of Hamas that
it stayed in a state of poverty but if
you look at the facts it's actually the
blockade uh two decades of it almost by
the Israelis that have prevented uh
people in Gaza from leaving unless it's
specifically uh warranted for work to
work the Israeli lands those
agricultural lands in those Southern
towns um and also the other thing is
that they controlled everything
everything from Aid they have done and
they continue to do so from Aid to water
and food um so this will play into
clearly many opinions that that uh
support uh the Zionist movement
especially and including those far
rights figures in that farri government
all right let's continue the discussion
about what's happening across the region
we've got Muhammad sharawi with us here
in the studio good to have you back with
us so so let's start with the latest
line coming out the statement by bzel
smotrich saying Israelis will live in
Gaza is he just saying out aloud what
they're privately discussing in the
cabinet for the postwar plans of Gaza
well it seems that the
right-wing vision of the future is
imposing itself on netanyahu's strategy
that means this war is a preamble to
reconizing Gaza and putting it under the
control of Israel which is going to to
create huge deescalation in the region
therefore if the idea of uh eradicating
Hamas as a security threat to Israel is
not fully Satisfied by the Israelis now
the right wing is saying no no no we
want more than that so
basically the Hamas Factor becomes just
a justification for and putting new or
imposing new control over the the strip
therefore uh I think there is a grandio
plan among the rightwing in in Israel in
comparison what natano has verbalized in
his last speech well he talks about
encouraging the residents of Gaza to
emigrate but let's be honest here this
is not encouragement when according to
reports more than 70% if you destroy
More than
70% of gaza's buildings critical
infrastructure water electricity that's
that's a lot more than just
encouragement isn't it that's making the
place
uninhabitable we need to apply critical
discourse analysis and scrutinize these
phrases basically it boils down to
number one depopulation of Gaza that
means triggering all possible reasons
that life becomes urable and not only
the infrastructure but also the security
threat among gazans grows to the maximum
therefore there are two options either
Israel pushes those two plus million
gazin toward siai or other place or
other region number two is also
considering that Gaza becomes a source
of uh migration and then the the
Mediterranean becomes a passage from
Gaza to other places either in North
Africa in the mle Middle East and be
Europe so in the long run there is a
possibility that that Netanyahu will
play the immigration card to you know
push or to put more pressure on the
Europeans to provide him with what he
needs to maintain this war and by the
way we should also take into
consideration that his speech yesterday
was significant when he said the war
will continue for many more months so
this is going to be an extra
protracted of the conflict all right
thank you so much Muhammad
shawi